Tim Ferriss: Stephen, it's nice to see you.
Thank you for making the time today.
Stephen Wolfram: Nice to be here.
Tim Ferriss: I was impressed that just before
we started recording, when I fumbled an attempt
to recall when it was that we sat next to
each other, you very quickly said 2011 Wired
Health Conference and mentioned that you have
an archive.
So how do you search for something like that?
Stephen Wolfram: I keep an awful lot of stuff.
I've got all my email going back 30 years.
I have a habit of writing trip reports for
myself whenever I go to some event or something
like that.
And I have also scans of paper documents.
You weren't a paper document.
You're more recent than paper document, so
to speak.
But I have scans of, well it's like a quarter
million pages or so, paper documents that
I generated in the time in my life before
I went fully digital, so to speak.
And I also tend to record.
I record all the key strokes I type and screen
captures and all kinds of things like that.
And then —
Tim Ferriss: How would you use — I'm sorry
to — I was just going to ask, how do you
use the logging of the key strokes?
How would that be used?
Stephen Wolfram: I don't usually.
Tim Ferriss: You do not.
Stephen Wolfram: Usually I don't.
Occasionally I'll want to know — occasionally,
for example, some computer will crash in some
horrible way and it'll be like, oh, I just
lost a bunch of stuff.
Well, no I didn't, because I had it recorded.
Tim Ferriss: Ah.
Right.
Stephen Wolfram: That was the thing that caused
me like 25 years ago to start recording those,
is one crash.
And then I decided it's cheap to just record
everything like that.
And occasionally I'll do things like, oh,
I'm using a new keyboard.
Do I type faster or slower on my new keyboard?
Those kinds of things.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
And you can track that type of thing.
Stephen Wolfram: It's easy to answer that
question if you have that data.
Tim Ferriss: It's one thing to record or ingest
information, it's quite another to structure
your thinking.
And I, in the process of doing research for
this conversation, came across some discussion
on Reddit involving creating matrices.
So I wanted to explore your use of matrices
for different projects.
I'm just going to read a very, very short
section here, which reads, "I actively avoid
thinking about things where I don't have a
'matrix.'
I don't like to have 'disembodied ideas' floating
around."
Which is my current state of affairs, so I'm
selfishly asking this.
"Of course, when something is important enough
to me, I try to build a 'matrix' for it."
Could you give an example of what such a matrix
might look like?
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah.
What I mean by that is, some kind of framework
in which I'm doing something.
So for example, if I have a small idea about
molecular biology, I don't really have a good
place to put that idea.
If I'm doing a big project about molecular
biology where I'm building up a whole structure,
then I have a place to put that.
So it's that kind of thing.
I've been lucky enough, my main life work
is building our computational language, Wolfram
Language, which is this language that's supposed
to represent everything in the world computationally.
So a large number of ideas that I have about
how to represent things computationally can
wind up in the matrix, which is the Wolfram
Language.
Similarly, I've found, for example, writing
my blog-like, kind of writings-thing, that's
another kind of matrix into which I can put,
when I do historical studies of things, I'll
write a piece about that historical study
and that's a place to put it.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Stephen Wolfram: But when it's too small a
thing, I just don't have a place to put it,
and it tends to die on the vine.
Since you're asking about this, I've just
been exposing myself to a very bizarre experience.
Which is, I've just been finishing a project
that I started 50 years ago.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Stephen Wolfram: And in the process of doing
this — something that I started, I got interested
in when I was 12 years old, it's a question
about physics and about the second law of
thermodynamics and why randomness gets generated
in the world and so on.
I've made various pieces of progress on this
question over the years, but finally now with
a bunch of the things that we've done recently
in understanding fundamental theory of physics,
I think I can actually really nail this question.
So I've written a whole thing about the scientific
answer to that question, but then I thought
I should write a piece describing my 50-year
journey of trying to answer this question.
And so that got me back into, I'm looking
at all my calendars from 1983, and I'm looking
at all of these paper documents that I have
scanned and so on.
It's a very interesting experience, going
back and seeing what mattered from 1983 and
what didn't.
How did I get to the things that were important
in the end?
How did those come to be?
What were the kinds of steps that I had to
go through?
One of the things I really noticed, really
striking to me, is there's often a large amount
of time in which I was building some conceptual
framework for something.
Sometimes I had clues about how that framework
should work, I didn't even recognize the clues.
Just didn't understand it.
Finally, through the very slow process, I
build this intellectual framework, and then
I get some other clue.
I do some other computer experiments, something
else happens.
And then literally I can trace, because I
have all the file creation dates, all this
kind of thing, I can trace.
It was 15 minutes from the time when I saw
this to the time when I started writing this
and so on.
It's really remarkable how much years can
go by, but one's slowly building up the kind
of conceptual framework needed, and then it's
often very sudden to take the next step.
That was a striking thing to me.
Tim Ferriss: I want to ask a few follow up
questions about conceptual frameworks and
perhaps just request an example of what such
a conceptual framework might look like, for
people listening and for me, frankly.
But before we get to that, putting together
a blog post or an article that chronicles
your search for answers or exploration of
these open questions is quite an undertaking.
Reviewing calendars from 1983 and so on, I
would imagine requires a good amount of time.
Why do you do it?
Or is it the reward in the process of writing?
Is it something gratifying in the process
of writing?
Are you hoping to impart something to those
who read this piece?
Why do that?
Stephen Wolfram: That's a good question.
I was wondering it myself.
I thought it would be really easy, but it
wasn't quite so easy.
No.
I have done quite a lot of historical biography,
usually of other people.
I find that when I'm really trying to understand
an idea, I need to know where that idea came
from.
So for example, the things I'm doing right
now on the second law of thermodynamics thing,
second law of thermodynamics was developed
in the 1860s.
I think people took a wrong turn sometime
shortly thereafter.
So I think the thing that I've now figured
out is a little different from what people
had figured out at that time.
And so when I'm saying I think they took a
wrong turn, I really want to know how did
they come to take that wrong turn?
And so that's my next project for the next
week or so is going back and I collected the
material for it.
I get to go back and read all the original
sources of how people came to think about
those things.
But I don't feel confident that I know what
was going on until I can trace this person
took that move because they thought this and
they understood that and so on.
And I thought for myself, I was mostly, well,
a bit curious.
I thought it was sort of an interesting story.
It's a very rare case in history of science
that one actually has really precise, detailed
data on how some idea got developed.
And so I thought it's kind of an interesting
example of essentially computational history.
One thinks about computational X for all X.
This is computational history.
And it's like what can you do in computational
history?
What kinds of things can you expose in computational
The other thing that's interesting to me,
is when I go back and think about things that
I did or figured out 40 years ago, let's say,
I lived through it, but then when I looked
back I realized there were threads that could
be joined that I absolutely did not see at
the time.
Give you an example.
I was working on these simple programs.
What do simple programs do?
The big surprise was, even very simple programs
can do very complicated things.
That was something I didn't expect.
It was a violation of my intuition.
It took me a couple of years to come to terms
with the fact that that was possible.
Same time, several of actually top mathematicians
who were friends of mine were trying to work
on the things that I had uncovered.
They said, "Let's go do math on these things.
Let's figure out more stuff about them."
And they worked for a while.
I just found a bunch of their notes, actually,
from going through these things from 1984
and so on.
And they did a bunch of very sophisticated
math, and they couldn't figure out anything.
What I realized is, at the time I was just
like, okay, well I'm figuring out my things.
Their methods didn't happen to work, so what?
What I then realized, just now, is the big
innovation of mine was realizing that the
fact that they couldn't figure out anything
was itself a super interesting fact.
So in other words, there's this phenomenon
I call computational irreducibility, which
is basically the big picture of why they couldn't
figure anything out.
Usually you say, "I know the rules by which
some system operates."
So then you might say, "Okay great, I've got
it nailed.
I know everything about what's going to happen
in that system."
Well, that's not true.
Because if the rules define some computation,
to know what the system does, you can find
out by running the computation, the question
is can you outrun that computation?
Can you say, "Okay, system, you went through
a million steps of that computation, but I
don't need to do that.
I'm smarter than the system.
I can just say the answer is 42," or something.
What computational irreducibility tells you,
is that in general you are stuck having to
follow each step in the evolution of the system.
And that's a really important fact about science.
It's a way in which science explains from
within science that science has questions
that it can't readily answer.
The thing that I realized only, I don't know
what, 35 years after the fact, is that, in
a sense, if I had an achievement, intellectual
achievement in that whole process, it was
realizing that the fact that one had gotten
stuck was itself the most important thing
to know.
Not, "Oh, we got stuck.
Let's give up."
But the fact that one got stuck meant that
there was a paradigmatic change that had to
be made in the way that you think about these
kinds of questions in science.
So that's an example that, for me, is quite
useful, to go back and see what really happened
there, what was really important there, which
I had not realized at the time.
Tim Ferriss: Makes me — I was just going
to say, it makes me think a bit of the Sherlock
Holmes, the case of
the dog that didn't bark in the night.
The term that I'd love for you just to elaborate
on a little bit, and I apologize this is going
to be a muggle question, but for people who
are non-technical, I'll put myself in that
audience, when you say, for instance, computational
history or computational X, how should someone
who may have fear around the term "computational"
think of that term?
Computational history as an example?
Stephen Wolfram: We humans like to come up
with abstract, formal ways to describe things.
Language itself is an example of that.
We see things out there in the world and we
say, "That's a tree, that's a dog, that's
whatever."
The fact that we are able to symbolically
describe these things in the world — there
are many different kinds of dogs and many
different details, but we just say "It's a
dog" — so it's a way of organizing the things
that we see, in that case, just using natural
language.
There've been in history a variety of kinds
of organizational approaches.
Logic, for example, was one from antiquity.
Mathematics is another kind of organizational
approach to say, "This is how you structure
the way that you talk about the world."
As far as I'm concerned, the importance of
computation is, it's another way to structure
how you talk about the world.
And a big part of what I've spent my life
doing is building this kind of computational
language, which provides a precise way to
take something like, I don't know, some description
of some piece of food or some description
of some position on the Earth or whatever
else, and represent those things computationally
in a precise way that has the feature that,
well a human could read it and say, "Oh, I
know what that means."
But also we have the extra boost from the
fact that a computer can read it too, and
then the computer can help us to get further
with that.
I mean, in a sense, one of the big things
that we, as a species, you know, big achievement
is human language.
You can take of things about the world and
describe them in a somewhat precise, abstract
way.
I see computational language as being another
level in that evolution, except that we get
to share the burden of seeing what happens,
not just with other humans, but with computers.
And so, for me, that's the big thing is describing
the world computationally.
Now, when I talk about simple programs and
those kinds of things, what I tend to mean
is kind of a meta model of the world.
So there are models of actual trees and dogs
and trajectories on the Earth and things like
this.
And then how do you break that down to something
even more primitive?
And so then what you end up with are these
sets of rules that say, well, you could describe
what they are about in many different ways.
But for example, one type that I've studied
a lot, the technical name is cellular automata,
and the typical setup is you have a row of
cells, and each cell can be either black or
white, let's say.
And then the computational rule is, you look
at every cell and you say, what is the color
of that cell and its two neighbors, let's
say.
Based on that you say, okay, I'm going to
change the color of the cell to be white or
to be black or whatever.
You just keep running that rule over and over
again.
The big surprise is, and this is the thing
I finally discovered in around 1984, the big
surprise is that even with a rule that simple,
you can just start it off with one black dot
and it makes this incredibly complicated pattern.
A pattern so complicated that if you were
to just look at a piece of the pattern and
say, is this random or is there some regularity
to it?
You would just say, it looks completely random
to me.
Even though the rule that made it is this
very, very simple rule that you can easily
describe or write down or feed to a computer
or whatever else.
So for me, this notion of computation is having
this way to structure the way that you talk
about the world, and then there's this kind
of meta modeling of that, which is to say
what are the very simplest elements of that
computational process?
And then talk about what one can do with those.
I mean, I think a good analogy perhaps for
the computational description of the world
comes from the mathematical notation that
one uses to talk about mathematics.
I mean, it's sort of an interesting evolution
that if you look at mathematics done in antiquity
and things like that, people didn't have a
symbol for plus.
They just used words.
And then some time around 500 years ago, people
started inventing a plus sign, an equals sign,
things like this.
And it's when that sort of streamlining of
the way to talk about math came online, that's
where math really took off and algebra got
invented and then calculus and then we have
this whole mathematical approach to science
that was able to be done.
I guess my own personal last 40 years of effort
has been to try to make a computational notation
for talking about the world that is kind of
a parallel for computation of what mathematical
notation is for the mathematical way of talking
about the world.
Tim Ferriss: I have a question about natural
languages.
I don't think I'm misquoting, but feel free
to fact check this.
You are so deeply aware of and able to work
with language in multiple, I would say, dimensions.
I did read at one point you were considering
a job with CERN and I believe I read that
you said you had practiced French but had
never built up the nerve to use it, or something
along those lines.
And I don't know if that was the tongue-in-cheek
comment, but —
Stephen Wolfram: Well no, no.
That's from ancient times.
I went to fancy schools in England when I
was growing up.
I learned three languages, Latin, Greek, and
French.
Okay, you don't get to speak Latin or Greek,
ancient Greek, at least not in most places.
But French, you could in principle speak.
I can read scientific French pretty fluently.
But if you say — if I'm in France and I'm
like, "Can I order that piece of food or something?"
No way.
I can't do that.
It's one of these things.
I should get over it one day.
Because I think I have the vocabulary knowledge,
I think, and all that.
I just have never really gotten into that.
I've been very deeply involved in computational
language.
I've not been deeply — I've been interested
in human language, but I'm not from the point
of view of the practice of learning lots of
human languages.
It's one of those skills where I could have
put a lot of effort into it, but it’s like,
automatic translation is now getting to the
point where, for many kinds of things, not
so important anymore.
Just like I could have been a champion map
reader.
I'm glad I didn't put huge effort into that,
because I just use a GPS now.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's true.
I suppose I am the opposite in the sense that
I've spent a lot of time on natural languages,
in part because I derive so much pleasure
and I think cognitive exercise from pursuing
it, but looking at the progression, say, in
Google Translate from my last trip to Japan,
which was pre-COVID, to just about six weeks
ago, it is astonishing —
Stephen Wolfram: That's interesting.
Tim Ferriss: — how much it has improved.
Fortunately, I already speak, read, and write
Japanese reasonably well, because I went there
as an exchange student when I was 15, but
the extent to which someone can now use their
voice pretty synchronously to communicate
with someone with automatic translation is
remarkable.
Where do you see that, or how do you see that
developing, say, in the next handful of years
or in the near term?
I mean, this is something I would imagine
you probably have a view on.
But how do you think we'll be using this type
of technology in the next, call it five years?
Stephen Wolfram: I think one of the things
that it really drills into is the whole question
of can you actually express the same thoughts
in different human languages?
And that's a deep issue.
I think what we realize is that, language
is one representation of organized human thoughts.
In a sense, it is a societal construction
of we all know what a chair is.
So when we use the word "chair," we know what
each other is talking about.
But if you have a language that comes from
a place where the environment, the culture
is very different, you'll end up with words
where there really just isn't a translation
for that word.
Because there just isn't the shared cultural
understanding of what one's talking about
there.
So I think the thing that will be pretty interesting
to see is, as we see the tightening up of
the structural aspects of translation, at
what point do we really realize, in that culture
there are thoughts that we just don't have
in some other culture?
And that's something, as you start generalizing
that, it's like, okay, how do we communicate
with the alien intelligences?
How do you communicate with cats and dogs?
How do you communicate with AIs?
Things like this.
These are all examples of alien intelligences
with which we share certain kinds of things.
We share some emotional responses with pets
and things like this, but we don't share,
probably, some sort of deep philosophical
convictions and so on.
It's interesting to see how this process of
translation can work and how far out can you
translate things.
I guess for computers, the thing I've been
most involved in, is how do you go from the
things we think about in our minds to the
things that we can represent for a computer?
And how do we — computers can compute all
kinds of things.
Many of the things they can compute, we humans
don't at least currently care about.
There's a certain small set of possible things
computers can do that are things that relate
to the things that we humans in the current
state of our civilization and so on have decided
we care about.
And so an interesting question to understand,
to what extent we can translate the things
we think we care about into something which
can be represented computationally?
And it comes back again, I suppose after one's
spent one's life working on something, everything
somehow relates to these questions like, how
do you make this computational language to
represent human thoughts in a computational
way?
Now, when you talk about natural language
translation and so on, what we've done when
we make our Wolfram|Alpha system and intelligent
assistant uses of that and so on, what it's
doing is it's taking a natural language question,
like what's the population of India divided
by China in 1960 or something?
And it's taking that and it is turning that
into a precise computational question, precise
symbolic representation that we can then compute
the answer from.
But whatever poetry there might have been
in that question, can you tell me the population
of the, I don't know, some poetic name for
some country and some other thing.
We crush all the poetry out of that.
We're just turning it into, so what is the
precise computational representation that
is good computer speak, so to speak.
Whereas it could have been that the very appreciative
way that somebody described some country translated
into some other human language, that notion
of appreciation would've been the most important
part of that thing that one's asking.
But for the computer it says, "I don't care
about that.
I'm just here to provide a symbolic representation
and give the answer," so to speak.
I think the thing to understand about translation,
ultimately, is the destination mind isn't
built the same way the source mind is necessarily
built, and so there may just be no way to
change that.
Now, you know can see that.
If you imagine you have two machine-learning
neuralnet systems and they've both been trained
how to tell cats from dogs, for example, the
internal methods by which they will do it
will typically be quite different.
The details of how they will have reacted
to that training will be quite different.
And so there isn't a direct translation.
System A does it this way inside.
Its most important thing is that the tail
has this form, or something like this.
So there isn't this direct internal translation.
Just as for humans, even if we could do brain-to-brain
transfer of thoughts, it's not really going
to work.
Just like when you have two machine-learning
systems, the details of how they learnt things
inside will be different.
And that thought experiment, so to speak,
about thoughts, of direct transfer of thoughts,
that also applies.
The thing that is the robust transfer of thoughts
is basically language.
The thoughts themselves are not directly transferable,
but we package them into language, which is
this formal representation of thoughts that
we can transfer from one mind to another,
so to speak.
I think that's my way of thinking about that
at least.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
This underscores, I think, part of the appeal
for me in learning these languages, even when
they really have very little utility.
I was just studying Romanian, which has very
limited use.
A part of the fascination is, as you're mentioning,
these concepts or labels that take the form
of language, even if the translations, literal
translation, can be conveyed to the target
mind, the nuance can be much more challenging
to convey.
And I find exploring the language is a way
to better understand the thinking of a target
population, whether Japanese or Romanian,
to be a lot of fun.
Because for instance in Japanese, there are
at least 40 or 50 ways to say "no."
But they might take the form of, "Well, that's
very difficult," or, "Maybe that's possible.
Let me ask Mr. Takahashi."
And those all mean "no."
But the translation won't necessarily convey
that.
And also thinking about, and I'll stop my
mini TED Talk here in a second, but the structure
of the language, let's just say something
as simple as subject verb object.
"I eat the apple" versus "I, the apple eat,"
which you would find in Japanese and then
in German you would find it, but only in certain
cases where it's a relative clause.
And all of that, I think, represents, often
represents fundamental differences in how
people process reality.
So I really enjoy it.
Now, let me ask you a question about the type
of scientific forensic analysis that you've
done.
Where you're looking at how someone took a
left turn, in say, thermodynamics at some
point in time.
I have not read this book of yours, but Idea
Makers.
It's a compilation of essays.
How did you choose the players on the field
for this?
How did you choose the people you included?
Stephen Wolfram: Oh, it was always opportunistic.
I'm afraid some of it was somebody died and
I knew them and I wanted to write an obituary
post.
Others were, somebody was having a big anniversary
and there was a big shindig associated with
that, so rather opportunistically.
But it happened to cover a rather nice collection
of different types of folks from Dick Feynman
and Steve Jobs, who were both people I knew,
to people like Ada Lovelace and Ramanujan,
who are people who died long before I was
born.
Tim Ferriss: So Dick Feynman, I'd love to,
if you would indulge me, just to tell me a
bit of your experience with Dick Feynman.
I own the set of Encyclopedia Britannica that
he bought when he was, I think, 43 years old.
I ended up buying it on my 43rd birthday as
a reminder to never stop searching and learning.
Stephen Wolfram: That's cool.
Tim Ferriss: And I drew a few diagrams of
his as well, which I prize.
And I wish I knew more physics.
I really enjoyed it when I was younger.
I did not pursue it to an advanced level at
all.
I really wish I could appreciate his genius
in a higher fidelity way.
But what was it like to spend time with him,
and how did you know him?
What was he like in person?
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah, I met him when I was
18 and he was 60.
Okay?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Stephen Wolfram: And he would always say,
"I was as quick as you were, but now I'm three
times older than you are."
No, he could be quite competitive in those
kinds of things.
But the thing that I liked about him, whenever
I see it, is he just would think about anything.
It's like the thinking apparatus is engaged
and will stay engaged, whatever the topic,
so to speak.
And he liked drilling down to really get,
"What is the real point?
What's the essence of what's going on?"
And sometimes he would play a little trick
on the world, which was one of the things
he was really good at was calculating things
by hand.
He used computers a little bit, but mostly
hand calculation, complicated math, these
kinds of things.
And so he would do, he'd have some question,
he would do all this complicated math to work
out the answer.
Then he would get this answer, and then he
would think, "Well, how can I have figured
out that answer by just some intuitive argument
without having to go through all the complicated
math?"
I remember talking to him about this.
He thought that everybody can do the complicated
math, but it's really impressive if you can
figure this out by intuition.
And so he would then figure out this intuitive
answer, throw away the math, tell people only
the intuition.
There's some fields where he did that.
And people are like, "We don't know how on
Earth he figured this out."
And people have been trying to reverse engineer
the math for years, but that was one of his
little clicks on the world, so to speak.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's incredible.
Intellectual sleight of hand.
Would Ramanujan — this is someone I know
even less about.
I personify the intuition that Feynman was
referring to, or on some level —
Stephen Wolfram: Well, Ramanujan is a different
story.
Ramanujan was a slightly decently educated
person just hanging out in India and producing
remarkable mathematical results.
Ramanujan, like Feynman, was a very good calculator.
And it really confused the mathematicians
because he would say, "I've got this amazing
formula for Pi.
Nobody's ever seen anything like it."
And he'd say, "Here it is."
And then when he started corresponding with
mathematicians in England in 1913, or whatever,
they were like, "Well, how did you prove this?
How do you know this?"
And eventually he got so fed up, I think,
that he told them, "Well, the goddess so and
so told it to me in a dream."
But the truth of it was, he was a really good
calculator.
And so he just worked out, this particular
series is the same as Pi to this number of
decimal places.
And he had good enough mathematical intuition
to say, "And it's just going to be correct.
It's not just going to be an approximation,
it's going to be exactly right."
Occasionally, that intuition failed him.
He had a result about prime numbers, for example,
where he had done many, many, many cases and
it looked like it was true.
Turns out the result isn't true.
But the first exception is that 10 to the
10 to the hundred or something, some huge
place which he couldn't reach with calculation.
So in a sense he was, I think, a great experimental
mathematician.
Had he used computers, he would've had a whole
different set of things he could've discovered.
But even with himself as the computer, so
to speak, he was discovering all kinds of
things.
And literally, the mathematicians of the time
had never seen anything like it.
And so for them, it just seemed to be this
magical thing where he was just pulling formulas
from nothing.
A bit like Dick Feynman.
He was often pulling formulas from a lot of
hard work of computation.
And I remember when I was younger, I happened
to start using computers to do physics very
early on when I was a teenager, and so on.
And for some reason the tools existed, but
to be able to do some mathematical computations
by computer, but people weren't using them.
One of the experiences that I had when I was
a kid was I discovered the fact that computers
can be really powerful for doing science and
so on when I was 13, 14, 15 years old.
And I started using them to do that, and I
started being able to derive all kinds of
complicated mathematical formulas and so on
by computer.
For whatever crazy reason, other people just
weren't doing that.
And so I could write physics papers where
I would have these very elaborate formulas
that I derived, and so on.
And people were like, "You must be amazingly
good at doing all this calculational stuff."
And it's like, well no, actually.
I'm actually pretty bad at it, but me with
a computer we’re pretty good.
But they didn't really even understand the
fact that that was a thing back in those days.
Yeah, I've seen this interesting phenomenon
of when you use tools where people don't necessarily
even understand that those tools exist it
has some interesting consequences.
I find, for me —
Tim Ferriss: I was just going to say, the
attribution, I'm going to skip.
But what was it, any sufficiently advanced
form of technologies indistinguishable from
magic?
Something like that.
I can't remember what the attribution would
be.
Stephen Wolfram: — Arthur C. Clarke.
Tim Ferriss: I think that sounds like Arthur
C. Clarke.
Stephen Wolfram: Right.
Yeah.
No, I think that the thing that I've spent
a lot of my scientific effort getting intuition
from doing computer experiments.
In another age I would've been there with
test tubes and other things doing physical
experiments.
Thank goodness I can get away with doing computer
experiments, because it's a lot better for
me, so to speak.
But you do these experiments and there's a
certain art to doing a good computer experiment,
but you can discover things that you never
thought were there, and they inform your intuition
and allow you to build things up.
And it's this thing that comes from nowhere.
Because it's just coming from not the natural
world, but the computational world.
You're just turning over this rock in the
computational world and suddenly you discover
that there's this whole crazy thing going
on underneath it, so to speak.
Tim Ferriss: I would love to pose a question
that was posed at a group dinner I attended
not too long ago, and it's related to what
the moderator called heresies.
And I'll unpack what that means.
He asked each of us to present a heresy.
And the heresy in this context was something
that the people in this small group, about
six to eight people, would disagree with you
about.
And these were a lot of technical folks.
And I think each person in the group could
have put out many things they believed that
the broader population would disagree with
them about.
But are there any particular beliefs that
you have or scientific insights, computational
insights, this could be related to the Physics
Project, could be related to other things?
Things you believe that you have high conviction
in that many people would disagree with you
on now, but let's just say hopefully 10 years
from now looking back they would say, "Ah,
yes, that was actually, in fact, had some
grounds to it."
Does anything come to mind?
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah, there's several, but
there's one example of a big one.
But this one, the resistance is crumbling
rapidly, maybe it doesn't quite count as well.
But I think it would still be the case that
if you poll, let's say physicists, the resistance
would not have completely crumbled.
And that's the question of, "What is space?
And is space made of anything?"
So go back, let's say 120 years.
People said, "What's water made of?"
Water isn't made of anything.
Water is just a fluid that flows in the way
it flows.
Turns out what became clear than the late
19th century, is actually water is made of
something.
People have guessed it much earlier, it's
made of molecules.
So the question now is, "What is space made
of?
This thing that we move around in, is it just
a thing where we get to place something wherever
we want?
Or does it have an inner structure?"
And I've been pretty sure for quite a while
that space has an inner structure, it's just
made of these discrete atoms of existence.
You can think of in the case of space, atoms
of space.
And all that one can say is how these atoms
of space are connected to other ones.
So there's this giant network that defines
the structure of space, and that's what space
ultimately is.
And everything that exists in the universe
is a feature of the way those connections
work in the underlying structure of space.
That's kind of like, if you have a fluid,
there's a bunch of these molecules bouncing
around.
But let's say you just look at little vortex,
little eddy on the surface of the fluid, little
whirlpool type thing.
We can say, there's a whirlpool, you can see
it go by.
And we can talk about it and so on.
But ultimately, it's just made of a bunch
of molecules moving in a particular organized
fashion.
And it's my strong belief that everything
we know in the universe, all the electrons
and photons, and the things we that get made
up of those, they're all just things like
eddies in the structure of this giant network
that is the underlying data structure of the
universe, and the underlying thing that space
is made of.
So that's something —
Tim Ferriss: Where would dark matter fit into
this, be vetoed by this, be compatible or
incompatible with this?
Stephen Wolfram: It's kind of a detail.
The bigger picture is something which is a
more embarrassing feature of current physics.
Dark matter is the rotations of galaxies look
like there's more stuff inside the galaxy
than you can account for by looking at the
luminous stars and so on.
But there's a bigger embarrassment, which
is that in quantum field theory, the standard
theory of the way small scale stuff happens
in physics, there is this phenomenon called
zero point fluctuations.
And there are an infinite collection of zero
point fluctuations in the universe that essentially
produce energy, or are associated with energy
that has a gravitational effect that will
roll the universe up into a tiny ball.
That is not what we see.
We see a universe that's a big universe, not
a universe that's just rolled up into a tiny
ball.
And so that's, in terms of missing energy,
that is a much bigger by a factor of a hundred
orders of magnitude or more.
That's a bigger problem, so to speak, than
the dark energy problem.
But that's a dark matter problem.
Dark energy is yet a different problem.
But these are all features of, there's aspects
of the universe where there's energy, but
where the energy doesn't seem to have the
effect that we would expect to have, or we
don't know where the energy is coming from,
and so on.
One feature of our of model of physics is
that the very processes that are leading to
those vacuum fluctuations and so on, those
are the processes that knit together the structure
of space.
So in the usual theory, it's like there's
space and that's a thing.
And then there's all this matter that is doing
all these weird quantum fluctuations in space,
and that matter should have more of an effect
on space.
But in our models, those quantum fluctuation-like
things, those are what make space.
And so it's not surprising, and the math works
out this way, that the thing that makes space
doesn't itself have the effect on space of
doing something like curling the universe
up into a tiny ball.
That's an example of how something like that
works out in our model of physics.
Tim Ferriss: I do have a question about time,
which I'll get to in a second.
But any other heresies that would be on the
short list of things that come to mind?
Stephen Wolfram: Oh, boy.
Here's another one, it's a little bit more
detailed.
See, what's happened is, as a result of the
Physics Project we have come to understand
a different paradigmatic way of thinking about
a bunch of things.
And so there are a bunch of fields that you
can then apply this new paradigmatic way of
thinking to, and start to make foundational
changes in those fields.
I'll mention another thing, I don't know how
much of a heresy this is.
But in physics, the two big theories of physics
— well, there are really three big theories
of 20th century physics: general relativity,
Einstein's theory of gravity, quantum mechanics,
and statistical mechanics.
Which is what brings us things like the second
law of thermodynamics, the law of entropy
increase, and so on.
And it's the theory of heat, so to speak.
Those are the three big theories of 20th century
physics.
One of the things that I think is just super
amazingly cool, is it's turned out that all
three of those theories are basically come
from the same place.
They're all in a sense versions of the same
statement.
They're all in some sense the same theory.
Which, to me, is really remarkable.
And in fact, one of the things that has just
become clear to me now is that the people
have thought — well, okay, so statistical
mechanics is about when you put lots of molecules
together, what do they typically do?
For example, you can have molecules that make
a gas, and you say there are certain gas laws
that determine the pressure and volume of
the gas, and so on.
These are typical things that happen when
you just throw a bunch of molecules altogether.
That's what statistical mechanics is about.
And people have believed that the most significant
thing in statistical mechanics, the second
law of thermodynamics, which is the law that
says things tend to get more random.
When you have mechanical work that's doing
things, eventually that's dissipated as heat.
And once it's heat, that's microscopic motion
of molecules, you never get back that large
scale mechanical motion.
It's turned into heat, it's random, you don't
get anything back from it.
People have believed that it's possible to
derive the second law of thermodynamics in
some kind of almost mathematical way.
You don't really need to know physics to be
able to derive that principle that things
tend to, for example, go from mechanical work
to heat.
But people have believed that general relativity
and quantum mechanics are both wheel-in features
of our universe.
They're both things where you could have made
a universe that didn't have one of those things,
they're just things where it happened to be
that way.
What has become clear from our Physics Project
is that all three of these theories of come
from the same place, and they're all as derivable
with each other.
And they're all derivable in a really interesting
way.
They're all derivable ultimately from this
strange thing we call the ruliad, which is
this limit of all possible computations.
The entangled limit of all possible computations.
And what turns out to happen is all three
of those theories are the results of observers
like us sampling this ruliad object.
And what matters is that we have certain attributes
as observers.
For example, we are computationally bounded.
We can only fit a limited amount of computational
stuff into our minds.
We can't describe, oh, here's where every
atom in the universe went.
In our minds, the narrative that we have for
describing the universe is far away from,
let's describe where every atom went.
We're just talking about these much more filtered
versions of what's going on in the universe.
That turns out to be one of the important
things.
The other one is that we believe we are persistent
in time.
In other words, even though at every moment
we are made from different atoms of space,
we are being the atoms of space that we were
at one moment are being destroyed, new ones
are being created and so on.
Despite that, we believe that we are persistent
in time.
It's like the little eddy on the water.
The molecules that make that eddy, it's different
molecules at every moment in time.
Yet there is a definite thing, which if the
eddy had a mind, so to speak, it could think
it is persistent in time.
Those two features that our minds are computationally
bounded and we believe we are persistent in
time, those two features determine how we
sample this ruliad thing, which is the ultimate
limit of all possible processes.
And the sampling that we get to do is one
that gives us those three features, those
three big theories of 20th century physics.
Tim Ferriss: How do you spell ruliad?
Stephen Wolfram: R-U-L-I-A-D.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I got it.
Look at that.
Incredible.
Now, is there a lay explanation or exploration
of the ruliad that isn't completely corrupted?
That someone like —
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah, I think so.
Tim Ferriss: — myself might digest?
Stephen Wolfram: The first thing to think
about is, there's a little bit of a story
that gets to it.
One of the things I've long been interested
in is, is there a simple rule from which where
you just run that rule long enough and you'll
get everything that happens in the universe?
In other words, I was talking before about
how simple computational rules you run them,
they do really complicated things.
The most complicated thing we know about is
the whole universe, so could we find a rule?
Or we just write down this rule and we could
run it long enough, it would just make the
whole universe.
Okay, then you start thinking, well, let's
imagine that we had that rule.
Let's imagine that we'd found that — let
me go actually one other place first, which
is how quantum mechanics works.
In classical mechanics you have laws that
describe how things move, or what happens
in the world.
There might be something that says, I throw
a ball with a certain velocity, it will move
in a certain trajectory.
Tim Ferriss: And by classical, you mean Newtonian
in this case?
Stephen Wolfram: Newtonian physics, yes.
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Stephen Wolfram: Actually, the relativistic
physics works the same way.
That's the distinction between classical as
in not quantum and quantum.
The dividing line is around 1920, it's about
100 years old, the thing.
And so, in the quantum view of the world,
it isn't the case that definite things happen.
Instead, the quantum view is there are many
paths that get followed.
That was Dick Feynman’s idea, this idea
of path integrals and following many quantum
paths.
But the notion is that in quantum mechanics
lots of different things happen.
The ball goes on many different possible trajectories.
We, as observers of what happened, we get
to sample across those possibilities and just
get to say, "Oh, there was a certain probability
that this would happen.
There's a certain probability that would happen."
That's the traditional view of quantum mechanics.
In our models you have this giant graph that
represents this giant network, that represents
the structure of the universe.
And it's continually being rewritten according
to some rule.
What turns out to happen is, there are many
different possible rewrites that could occur.
Those different possible rewrites give you
these different paths of history.
They give you essentially different threads
of time, so to speak.
Different possible things that could happen
in the universe.
Those threads of history, sometimes they branch,
because two different things could happen
next.
Sometimes they merge, because two things end
up producing essentially the same universe.
So you end up with this whole complicated
structure of branching and merging of possible
histories for the universe.
So now the question is, how do we perceive
what's going on in that universe?
And why do we not see the universe as this
thing where it's branching all over the place?
And how can we tell what's happening?
Well, the thing we have to realize is that
we ourselves are embedded in this branching
universe.
So our minds are branching just like everything
else in the universe is branching.
It turns out the core question of how one
perceives quantum mechanics is, how does a
branching mind perceive a branching universe?
And so then this thing that I mentioned that's
a feature of us, is we believe that we are
persistent in time.
And so even though in some sort of external
God's eye view, so to speak, the universe
is branching like crazy, we believe that our
minds are going through a single thread of
experience.
And so that means as we impose that belief
on what's actually going on in the universe,
we conflate lots of different paths that from
the outside would look like the universe is
doing different things.
But we so know, actually, those are all in
some sense the same thing, because that's
what we have to believe in order to have this
conceit that we have a definite thread of
experience.
And so that process is what drives the understanding
of how quantum mechanics works.
And actually, returning to Dick Feynman again.
He always used to say that having worked his
whole life on quantum mechanics, he always
was very fond of saying nobody understands
quantum mechanics.
And I talked to him for ages and ages about
that.
And I wish he was still around because I think
I can finally say I think I actually understand
quantum mechanics.
And it's just this idea of the branching mind
perceiving the branching universe.
I hadn't seen that coming at all.
And it's a bizarre idea that turns out, I
think, to unlock how that works.
But okay, in quantum mechanics we have all
these different possible things that could
happen in the universe, which to us get conflated
together into a definite path.
Well, okay, let's say we've got this model
and we say we find this rule, and this rule
represents everything the universe does.
So then we might imagine this day where we've
got this rule comes out of our computer, we've
done some search and we have rule number 713
is our universe.
For a long time I was just really uncomfortable
with that idea.
Because let's say we're universe 713, the
next question is, why did we get number 713?
Why didn't we get number seven trillion, whatever?
Why this one?
One of the big lessons of science over the
last 500 years is the Copernicus lesson.
We're not very special.
We might have thought the Earth was the center
of the universe.
We might have thought these kinds of things,
but it isn't true.
We're just on a random planet somewhere in
this random space that makes up the universe.
Even the idea that our rule is a simple rule,
as opposed to an incredibly complicated rule,
seems very anti-Copernican.
This really bothered me for a long time.
And I realized, actually, something even more
bizarre may be going on.
Which is, maybe the universe is not picking
any particular rule, it's running all possible
rules.
And so what the ruliad is is this computational
process that runs all possible rules.
So imagine you had all possible computers
and you start them off from all possible starting
points, and you run them all.
You might say, "How could that do anything
interesting?"
The critical point is that sometimes those
computers will end up making the same thing.
In other words, two different computers might
end up having being producing something which
is the same, has the same structure.
And so you might say, "Well, they're just
all going to do their independent things."
Well, they don't do independent things because
there are all these equivalences between things
that they do.
And so you end up building up this rich structure,
and that structure you build up is what we
call the ruliad.
It's the entangled limit of all possible computations.
And what's really interesting about it is,
there's only one of it, and it is a necessary
object.
In other words, as soon as you define that
you're talking about the notion of computation.
As soon as you define your terms, you have
the ruliad.
It's not the case that it's like, oh, it so
happens that this feature of the world is
this way.
It is as inevitable as, once you define what
integers are and what plus signs are, and
so on.
Two plus two equals four.
There's no way of getting out of that.
It's not something that is a random fact about
the world that humans happen to have two eyes
and a nose type thing, which might be seen
to be more coincidental.
It's something that is a necessary feature
from the formal structure of what you've set
up.
So the ruliad is this necessary object.
And now the thing which is interesting is,
okay, so you have this object that is this
limitable possible computations.
How do we experience that?
Well, we are also part of that object.
So it's the same story as the branching mind
perceiving the branching universe, except
an even more abstracted version of that.
It's, how do we as elements inside this ruliad
perceive the whole ruliad?
One of the things one starts talking about
is this notion of what we call rulial space,
which is the space of kind of possible different
views of how the universe works.
So we might say we've got one view of the
universe, "Oh, it works this way, it follows
this rule."
And then some other person, alien, whatever,
says, "No, no, no, you're quite wrong.
The universe really works according to this
other rule instead."
Now the reason, what knits all of that together,
is a kind of technical fact that's been known
for about a hundred years, which is this idea
of universal computation.
You might have thought that if you wanted
to have a computer that was a word processor,
you'd buy a word processing computer.
You want to have a spreadsheet computer, you'd
buy a spreadsheet computer.
But the big fact that emerged in the 1920s
and 1930s is that you can have a single sort
of hardware object.
I mean, it wasn't put to practice until the
1940s and '50s, but it was, you can have the
single hardware object that can just be programmed
to be a word processor, be a spreadsheet,
whatever.
And it's kind of the same thing with the universe,
that you can attribute different rules to
the operation of the universe, but they're
convertible, in the same way as your computer
can be made to run a spreadsheet rather than
a word processor, so to speak.
So —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, finish your thought and
then I want to pause for a second, ask a follow-up.
Stephen Wolfram: So one of the things that
I really kind of like about this is there's
this notion of where are you in rulial space?
Where what kind of mode of description of
what's going on in the world do you have?
And you can imagine that every different mind
is at a different place in rulial space.
So the fact that you and I have different
internal models of the world is a statement
of the fact that we are some distance apart
in rulial space.
And so what you realize is, as we think about
the universe, we have the exploration of the
universe by spacecraft or whatever going out
in physical space.
We also have the exploration of the universe
in rulial space.
And that's kind of, the different minds and
different ways of describing the universe
represent kind of travel through rulial space.
And just as we kind of, when we send out spacecraft
in physical space, we're exploring different
parts of the physical universe, when we come
up with different ways of thinking about things
and different ideas, we're kind of traveling
in rulial space.
And that's kind of a way to start representing
those kinds of things.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
I'm going to ask a number of questions that
will no doubt put me at risk of embarrassing
myself, but I knew that I when I —
Stephen Wolfram: I have to say one more thing.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, just —
Stephen Wolfram: Because you were asking about
languages and you were asking about different
human languages.
That's an example of being in different places
in rulial space.
So you can imagine two languages where the
way of thinking about the world is very similar,
they kind of correspond to nearby places in
rulial space, where it's pretty easy to translate,
to travel from one to the other, whereas things
which are very different, very different sort
of views of the world are further away in
rulial space.
And that's just a way of perhaps conceptualizing
what this thing is about.
Please, go ahead.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, when you said that, I was
just thinking about gendered languages versus
gendered languages or certain languages that
don't conjugate, say, past tense, like Chinese,
Mandarin, and how that affects maybe where
you stand in rulial space.
So how does a branching mind perceive a branching
universe or the branching might perceiving
the branching universe?
I think as many people hear this, they imagine
these multiple or infinite possibilities branching
out in some form of to conjure the image of
the eddy, so these changing atoms, but if
you took a snapshot of the eddy, minute after
minute, it would have some resemblance.
But there is a branching that I think for
many folks listening will take place in linear
time, and so there's some past to future to
this branching.
I have tried to stretch the boundaries of
how I consider or define time by reading and
listening to say, Carlo Rovelli, who I think
focuses a fair amount on quantum gravity.
I don't know his research very well.
How do you think about time?
Is how humans experience or think about time
Just a very convenient collective delusion
in terms of its linear past to future nature?
Stephen Wolfram: So I mean, first thing is,
what is time?
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
Stephen Wolfram: That's something that I think
we really kind of nailed in the way we think
about our theory of physics.
I mean, time is the inexorable progress of
computation.
So in other words, the universe is in some
state, then the universe is going to be transformed
to another state, and another one.
That progressive process of transformation
is the passage of time.
And this phenomenon of computational reducibility
that I was mentioning before that you kind
of can't jump ahead, that is the fact that
time is meaningful.
There is something, you can't just say, "Oh,
I didn't have to go through those moments
of time.
I could always just jump ahead."
Now, in most of the universe, time is just
progressing.
It's just as the universe is sort of updated,
so that corresponds to the passage of time.
Now, we are part of the universe, so we are
being updated too.
If the universe just stopped, we wouldn't
know it had stopped because we'd be stopped
too.
So for example, one place where that happens,
in the simplest kind of black hole, at the
center of the simplest kind of black hole,
is the space-time singularity, which has the
property that it's a place where time stops.
And so in our model of physics, what's happening
is this universe is being updated, this network
is being updated, being updated, but if you're
at the center of the black hole, it just stops.
There's no more update that can be applied.
Actually, if you're doing math, you kind of
want to get to that point.
If you're doing a calculation, you do, "Oh,
we're calculating.
These things are happening," and eventually,
you get to the answer and that's a place where
it's fixed, nothing changes anymore.
That's what happens at the center of a black
hole.
It's kind of bad news in a sense, if you want
to have a future, so to speak, because time
just stopped.
So time, as far as I'm concerned, is this
inexorable progress of computation and time,
in the actual way that it manifests in the
universe, has many complicated features.
So for example, in relativity and gravitation
theory and so on, there are all kinds of ways
in which the notion of, "When is it the same
time as somewhere else?"
Is complicated.
Like we say, let's say, have a Mars colony
one day and we define Earth standard time.
Okay, it's 12 noon at this point.
Well, it's 20 light minutes away to Mars,
for example.
Do we say that the 12 noon is the time when
the light signal from our clock that said
it was 12 noon on Earth reaches Mars?
Or do we try and back calculate that and say,
"Well, it's the time when it would've reached
if the clock had been 20 minutes early?"
And so on.
That whole question of the way in which you
kind of put these slices across the universe
to define what counts as simultaneity in time,
that's kind of the story of relativity theory
and gravitation theory and so on.
And that's another kind of twist in this whole
thing.
But in quantum mechanics, the big issue is,
is there just one threat— thread of time
or are there many threads of time?
Now, we humans normally only perceive one
thread of time.
I've sort of wondered whether there's some
trance that people can go into that's kind
of a multi-way trance, where they actually
have multiple threads of experience that are
going on at the same time.
But for most of us, most of the time, it's
just there's a definite thread of experience
that we have.
And that's a —
Tim Ferriss: If I may interrupt for a second,
what prompted that wonder or question about
whether there are people through —
Stephen Wolfram: Because one of the features
of our model of physics is what ultimately
drives the mathematical structure of quantum
mechanics, is this assumption that we have
that we are persistent in time and that we
can conflate things to the point where we
have a single thread of experience.
If that isn't the case, then we've got a different
theory of quantum mechanics, because quantum
mechanics ends up being something which says,
"You do all this quantum mechanical stuff,
it has these many parts of history."
But in the end, we want to get an answer.
We don't want to be saying we've got two different
answers in mind.
We're going to say, "We say a definite thing
happened."
And so for example, when people talk about
making quantum computers, the big thing that
one hopes for is that one can use these multiple
threads of history to each run a different
computation, and so then, you can do all these
things in parallel.
Now the big problem, and again, I seem to
be mentioning Dick Feynman too much here,
but he and I worked on quantum physics —
Tim Ferriss: Doesn't bother me.
Stephen Wolfram: — back in 1981 or so.
It was kind of a funny experience because
he did all his calculation by hand, and I
was using a computer.
I actually found one of the computations that
I did from that just recently, and he would
do these calculations by hand, and I had no
idea why the answers he got were right.
Because it's just like you do this calculation
and it's like, "You could have done this or
this or this, you could have made this or
this assumption at this point.
I don't know why that assumption is right."
And he'd look at the stuff I did on a computer
and he'd say, "I have no idea why any of that's
right."
So that was an interesting challenge, so to
speak.
But actually, even at that time, we kind of
concluded that the big question about making
use of quantum mechanics to compute things
is, "How do you determine the answer?"
In the formal theory of quantum mechanics,
how does the measurement work in quantum mechanics?
How do you actually measure what happened
in the quantum process?
Well now, what we see is there are all these
threads of history, and at the end, us humans,
if we want to get a definite answer, have
to knit together all those threads of history.
And the big question is, "How hard is it to
knit together those threads of history?"
And if it's as hard to knit them together
as what you gain by having multiple threads,
then you don't get an advantage in the end.
And that's a difficult thing to figure out,
and it's something we're trying to figure
out.
I'm not hopeful about the true quantum advantage.
I think that the formalism of quantum mechanics
is super interesting.
And it's very, this whole idea of these, what
we call multiway graphs and this whole multiple
threads of history and so on.
That's a very interesting formal thing relevant
to many fields.
But this idea that you're actually going to
be able to make an engineering system out
of it and get this sort of quantum advantage,
less convincing.
It's also, as a practical matter, the whole
quantum computing effort has caused people
to think, "Oh, can we make computers out of
things other than electronics and semiconductors
and so on?"
And that's a completely worthwhile thing,
as well.
So the two ends are worthwhile.
I'm not sure that the middle is so worthwhile.
So that's our notion of time.
Now, in terms of people's perception of time,
it is this process of, we are undergoing these
computations, our minds are undergoing these
computations, and so is the rest of the universe.
And that's kind of, it's the alignment of
the computations going on in our minds with
the computation going on in the universe that
leads these different forms of time, the time
in thermodynamics of things sort of decaying
down to heat, or the time in the expansion
of the universe, things about cosmology and
so on.
The fact that all those different arrows of
time align is a consequence of the fact that
they're actually the same thing, they're all
just the sort of inexorable process of computation
that's happening in the universe.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to use a term that
is, might be frustratingly undefined, overused
to the point that it's often undefined, at
least.
But I'm going to ask this question anyway,
which is, do you have any thoughts on what
constitutes consciousness?
It can be defined any way you want, or it
can just be tossed.
Or if that is an emergent property or a subjective
experience with certain underpinnings that
can be currently explained?
How do you think about, if at all, this may
be a terrible question —
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah.
Well, I've always sort of avoided it because
it's always seemed like a deeply slippery
thing.
But I was literally confronted with, "I need
to apply the idea of consciousness."
I may not have to — and here's how.
In the universe, ultimately there are all
these possible computations that can happen,
but our minds don't do all possible computations.
Our minds are somewhat more, they're much
more filtered in what they do.
And in particular, they have these features
of computational boundedness, belief, and
persistence and so on.
For me, those are the things we need to use
about consciousness to derive things in physics.
So those are features of consciousness that
distinguish us from the rest of the universe.
It's kind of actually a little disappointing
because we might have thought, "Oh, there's
inanimate matter and there's this and that,
and we've got this big stack we're building
and it goes through life.
And eventually, we get to intelligence, consciousness.
We are the tippy-top.
We are the best thing in the universe," so
to speak.
But actually, what I've come to realize is
that that's not true at all, that the universe
has much more capability than we have.
And this thing we call consciousness is a
filtering of that capability to something
specific, where we believe, for example, that
there's a single thread of experience that
we have.
And that that's kind of the thing that consciousness,
the application of consciousness to science
is this thing where it's not about everything
in the universe, it's just about the particular
things that are sort of the way that our minds
perceive things.
I think an exercise people talk about, "Well,
how can you talk about this in this kind of
very materialistic way?
Isn't there some magic thing in consciousness
that is this sort of spark that is different
from everything else in the universe?"
Well, to us, inside, there absolutely is.
To us, inside, we are this one point in rulial
space where there is this set of things going
on.
That is our experience of the universe, and
it's completely unique.
And there may be some other point in rulial
space, some other mind that is fairly close
by where we can say, "We're experiencing these
things.
We can tell that they're similar to what's
being experienced here."
But each sort of consciousness is unique in
that sense.
Now, I was kind of doing an exercise recently,
which I need to finish, which is to describe
what it's like to be a computer.
And you imagine we humans, we live our lives,
we remember a bunch of stuff through our lives.
Eventually, it's all lost when we die.
And the question is, for a computer, from
the time it boots up to the time the operating
system crashes, that's a period of time over
which the computer has sort of its life experiences.
And how do those life experiences compare
to the "life experiences" that we humans have?
There is a whole inner thinking that's going
on for the computer.
How does that compare with us humans?
There's sort of the communication with other
computers, the experience of the outside world
and so on.
How does that compare?
How can we describe that in what it's like
to be — even a current computer, forget
of the science fiction AI of the future, just
talk about a current computer.
What would it be like to be the sort of inside
that, experiencing things from the point of
view of the machine, so to speak?
Tim Ferriss: Let's segue to personal productivity.
So this is something I imagine you do still
think about a fair amount, and I've read a
fair amount of your writing on personal infrastructure
hacks and so on.
And it seems like there are, is I think you
might describe them, nerdy productivity hacks
that then later become more mainstream or
more accepted, more widely distributed.
Are there any personal productivity or infrastructure
tools or hacks that you are using now that
you think will gain more adoption in some
form in the not-so-distant future?
Stephen Wolfram: So I started live streaming
a bunch of working meetings that I do, and
started this about, when was it?
2017, so a few years ago.
And it's really an interesting process because
a large fraction of software design reviews
that we do are live streamed.
And that means people who are in the meeting
are a little bit more paying attention because
they kind of know it's going out to the world,
but it's also really nice because there's
kind of an immediate feedback.
If we announce some particular topic we're
going to work on, we'll get — some world
experts in that topic often will show up because,
gosh, they know they're going to be stuck
using our tools and they might as well contribute
to getting them to be designed right.
And also, people who are just energetic users
about technology.
And it's really a wonderful kind of immediate
feedback.
To me it's a little bit, it helps me feel
that the time I'm spending doing very detailed,
grinding away, trying to figure out how software
should be designed and so on, it feels like
the fact that I'm leaving some record of this,
feels like it makes it more meaningful.
And I know people have used some of our live
streams for software engineering classes and
things like this.
And so it helps me make it seem more meaningful,
so to speak.
The even more extreme version of that is that
I've been doing video work logs, which means
I'm just sitting by myself and I'm working
on something and I'm writing some document
or something like that, and I just record
it.
Like last night, I probably recorded five
hours of video work logs.
Basically was working on this sort of personal
journey history thing, and I'm recording my
screen and I'm just recording what I'm doing.
Now, why am I doing this?
Because it's easy to do and the thing that
— and somehow, it makes it feel a little
bit more meaningful to me.
It sort of makes me think, "Oh, I'm not going
to goof off in that way because I'm screen
recording everything here."
And okay, I admit, I have a secondary screen,
so I can goof off on the secondary screen.
And the other thing is, when I'm doing science
stuff, what has happened, a number of times,
is people say, "Well, how did you figure that
out?"
I'm saying, "You can really find out how I
figured that out.
Just go look at this video —
Tim Ferriss: Just watch it.
Stephen Wolfram: — and you can find the
minute where I figured this out."
And maybe I got it wrong, and you'll see,
"Look, he did something really stupid there."
And you can see that moment, and you can then
unwind it.
Same thing, by the way, for our software design
meetings.
The people who do project management routinely
go back and look at all kinds of pieces of
the meetings.
"What actually happened?
How did we decide this?
Oh, a bug showed up there.
Let's go carve that piece of the video out
and send it to people," and so on.
So I think this thing about doing actual production
meetings, so to speak, live streamed is — I
don't know anybody else who does that.
I think nobody else is crazy enough to do
it.
Stephen Wolfram: And part of why we can do
it is that we're in a unique place and technology
space, where it's not like — I know people
who wanted to compete with us have watched
live streams.
It's like, good luck.
We just spent 35 years building all this stuff.
One live stream is not going to let you rebuild
that tower.
So, that's one thing.
The other thing that I myself have become
confident enough that even though I know I'm
going to say really stupid things on these
live streams, I don't care.
These are real life things where, yes, I'm
going to make mistakes.
People are going to say, "You're wrong.
You're wrong."
And we're going to have a little argument,
and eventually, I'm going to say, "Hey, okay,
you're right."
And I don't have an internal ego issue with
either that process happening or that being
something that people can go back and find
it.
I'm sure it's possible to find all kinds of
terrible, stupid things that I said in these
live streams and so on.
Okay.
So, another productivity hack, I suppose,
related to live streaming is this.
So, at the beginning of the pandemic, I thought,
"Oh, all these kids are going to be out of
school.
I know a bunch of stuff about science."
Every so often I'll do a Q&A.
Once a week I'll do a Q&A about science and
tech for kids and others.
So I started doing this at the beginning of
the pandemic, and I've still been doing it.
I've done 100 episodes or more now of this
hour, hour and a half, on Fridays, of science
and technology Q&A for kids and others.
Okay, so what has that done for me?
People ask all kinds of crazy things, and
it makes me think about stuff.
And I find that this process of I'm just sitting
here, looking at the camera and no notes,
no looking anything up, just how can I figure
out the answer to that question.
And from a couple of days ago, there was a
question somebody asked that made me realize
some piece of physics that is relevant to
our Physics Project, that I'd never realized
before.
And the process of explaining it, particularly
with the forced feature that I'm just going
to go on talking at the camera, so to speak,
it's that forcing function of, "So now you've
got to figure something out," I found really
useful for understanding things.
And I've been doing actually two other alternating,
alternate weeks Q&As, one about history of
science and technology and the other about
business innovation and managing life, more
your territory.
And people there, again, I just find it really
helpful in crystallizing my own thinking that
I'm trying to answer these questions, particularly
in this real-time format, where I don't get
to say, "Oh, let me think about that, and
let me think some more about it and so on."
And then I never get around to answering it.
I'm kind of on the spot and having to answer
something, and that's been a very useful process.
I know that, in terms of explaining things,
science things, I'm pretty sure I can feel
that I've gotten better through hundreds of
hours of people ask random questions, and
I try and answer them.
The one thing that always trips me up is when
somebody asks a question, and I think to myself,
"That's really easy.
I have that one absolutely nailed."
Those are the ones that I trip up on.
And actually, there's a curious reason, which
I did realize about that, which is a lot of
these things, where it's like, I've understood
that since I was 12 years old.
So it's easy, and then I realize, oh, my gosh,
it relies on this thing and that thing and
the other thing, which, yeah, I learnt when
I was 12, 13 years old or something.
But not everybody knows that, and I have to
go explain that.
And I have to go explain this other thing
that I thought was obvious, and pretty soon,
one's descending into the swamp of complicated
stuff.
Tim Ferriss: So let's look at maybe, if there
is a there, there, we'll find out, some of
the physiological underpinnings of productivity.
So, we have these physical bodies, and you
seem to, this could just be my perception,
but have energy reserves.
I'm not using energy in a very precise, physics
way but more in a metabolic way.
Right?
You're producing enough neurotransmitters,
and you store enough glycogen and so on that
you are able to maintain, it seems like, a
very high rate of output.
Do you think about energy management in that
context?
Stephen Wolfram: You know what —
Tim Ferriss: Or is that something that just
comes so naturally out of the box that you
just have that advantage, and you don't have
to think about it?
Stephen Wolfram: I think I'm lucky that I'm
fairly energetic.
And it's always amusing to me that I'm an
old guy, now, and I can out energize lots
of young folk who are working with me and
so on.
And that always — Actually, I get a kick
out of being able to do that.
So that —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, why not?
Stephen Wolfram: — that helps add energy
to the whole picture.
But no, I think for me, look, one thing is
that I do things that I like to do.
And for me, that's a huge, energizing force.
If I was like, "Oh, gosh, I have to do this,
and I don't really want to do it, and I'm
not very interested," and it's like I'm jumping
into things, where I really want to do this.
It's like I was — okay, another strange
thing I just did, I seem to have been reliving
my life 50 years ago, in the last few weeks,
because I decided to organize, a couple months
ago, I initiated a reunion for my elementary
school graduating class, which was 1972.
And so, it's a small subgroup of people, and
so it was the 50-year follow up.
And actually, it was, I liked these people
50 years ago.
I liked them 50 years later.
That was nice.
But I realized one of the things that's a
little disappointing is some fraction of these
people were — we were writing little blurbs
about what we've been doing, and they're like,
"I retired."
"I retired," etc, etc, etc.
And they're British folk, so they had lots
of witty things to say about what they were
doing in their retirement.
But so, I was realizing, I'm not retired,
and I'm not even — and I realized I'd been
working more than 12 hours a day, every day,
for basically all of the last 50 years.
And I'm having a good time, and I've been
lucky enough to be able to mostly do things
that add energy to me rather than taking it
away.
When I do creative things, and I figure stuff
out and even write things and so on, that
the process of finishing them and getting
them done is energizing to me.
And I think, if I was doing things where I'm
like, oh, I don't know, back in the day, before
we realized this just didn't work, I would
occasionally go shopping with my wife.
Okay.
Wrong [inaudible 01:36:00].
Tim Ferriss: Uh-huh.
Stephen Wolfram: Right?
And I would try and take my wife to science
museums.
Okay.
So, my wife is a mathematician, so science
museums are not so far away, but they're far
enough away that she was like, "Oh, I'm getting
so tired walking around this science museum."
So, for me, it would have a physiological
effect on me, going around —
Tim Ferriss: Shopping.
Stephen Wolfram: — looking around shops.
I'm like, I feel really tired.
I have to —
Tim Ferriss: Getting so sleepy.
Stephen Wolfram: — lay down, etc, etc, etc.
So, I think the effect that I'm doing things
I really want to be doing is an important
effect.
Now, having said that, I did discover, when
I was 40 years old, hey, you should do some
exercise, and that helped for me, I think,
add a bunch of energy.
For the last three years, I've walked more
than 10,000 steps every single day, for the
last three years, and that's just one of my
constraints.
Even if I'm traveling or this or that or the
other, the people who schedule stuff for me,
it's like I've got to walk 10,000 steps.
If that's around an airport on phone calls
and things, so be it, but that's a constraint
on my life, so to speak.
And I think that has had a positive effect.
For me, it's been bizarre because, when I
was younger, I wasn't in terribly good shape.
I'm in better shape now.
And so, for me, I don't yet notice that I'm
aging because I'm actually better off, in
many ways, than I was when I was younger.
Tim Ferriss: Your mitochondria are getting
younger, are rejuvenating.
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah, yeah.
Right.
No, another thing about that and about the
management of one's life and so on, I've been
fortunate enough that, often, you'll do something,
and maybe you do something really cool when
you're 25 years old.
And then, it's all downhill from there, and
it's hard to get motivated.
And I've been lucky enough that, for example,
this Physics Project that just arrived, three
years ago, that was something I didn't really
expect.
It's a rejuvenating thing, and it's just added
a lot of energy to my — it's just there's
so many things to think about and so on.
That's one thing.
I sleep as close to eight hours as I can.
I don't try and game it of saying I'm going
to try and shave off extra time and so on.
I'm very habitual, in terms of when I go to
sleep, when I wake up.
Things I eat tend to be habitual, and they
may not be optimal, but they're habitual at
least.
I've found that, for me, I try and optimize
away all those aspects of my life that I really
don't care about, so to speak, that I don't
keep those as simple and not having to think
about them as possible so that I can spend
my thinking effort on things where I really
want to think about these things and really
want to spend my time on them.
But, yeah.
No, I've been fortunate enough that, for whatever
reason, the mitochondria are still alive and
kicking and providing good energy.
But as I say, I think it's mostly that just
doing things that I want to do, and also,
I tend to organize it so that there are things
that I save up for.
I'm going to do this if I'm feeling tired,
or I have another set of things.
I'm going to do this if I get sick.
Okay.
And I've had a whole bunch of those.
And I've only been sick once in the last three
years, so I didn't have a chance to — I've
got this big, pent-up supply of things to
do when I'm sick.
Tim Ferriss: Now, are those just low-energy,
low-interest tasks that nonetheless have to
get done, like talk to my accountant about
X, Y, Z, whatever, something like that?
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, I'm not usually talking to other people,
but usually organizing informational kinds
of things.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
I see.
Stephen Wolfram: Or sometimes, they're…
watch this video that I've been meaning to
watch and have never had time to do.
But I did learn, okay, so this is one not
yet very scientific hack fact, which is, I
was curious what has caused me to get sick
when I've gotten sick?
Why have I gotten sick?
And so I have the data for, I think, 27 years
maybe of, I think, all the times I've gotten
sick.
It's always upper respiratory things.
Right?
And so I think I've gotten sick 25 times in
27 years.
And the question is, what was I doing when
I got sick?
And was it, oh, I went out, and I met a bunch
of people, or was it whatever?
And the one correlation, and I haven't been
completely scientific about this, the one
correlation was it was often two days after
I was on a flight, on a plane.
Okay.
And in a few cases, that was not a commercial
plane.
That was a private plane, so without a lot
of other people on it, and so it's interesting.
And so then I asked my medical research friends
and so on, "Hey, what's going on here?"
And here's the theory.
The theory would be a big part of upper respiratory
defense, so to speak, is the innate immune
system operating in one's nose and so on.
And if you get your nose dried out and so
on, from being in the dry air and on planes
and things like that, your little, innate
immune system doesn't stand a chance.
So my hack has been take things like wheat
germ and so on that stimulate, just before
I go on a plane, take that and a couple of
other things, and so far, we only have an
N of about eight or something of trip side
time.
So far, I haven't gotten sick
Tim Ferriss: So far, so good.
It also makes me think of ways that you could,
not necessarily humidify, but maintain the
sort of moisture integrity of the sinal lining,
as well, with a spray or something like that.
Stephen Wolfram: Yeah, I thought about that.
My most relevant medical research friend claimed
it's easier to just take choline than it is
to try and do that.
Tim Ferriss: Try to keep the nose well hydrated.
Stephen Wolfram: Right.
It's a strange thing.
You're on some flight, going somewhere, and
you're continually stuffing things into your
nose or whatever.
No, that's —
Tim Ferriss: So, Stephen —
Stephen Wolfram: One of the things I found
that, for me, it's keep the list of things
to do when I'm tired because, for me, in terms
of motivation and so on, it's always nice.
If I'm sick, I might be like, "Oh, my gosh,
I'm sick.
That's so terrible."
But in a sense, I'm like, "Great, now I have
a chance to do these things that I knew I
had to do somehow."
I do the same thing when I'm driving places.
I always maintain a call-while-driving list
of phone calls that are slightly more, "I've
got to do this sometime.
I don't need to be in front of a computer."
This is something I can do then.
And it's actually good for lots of interactions
that I do, where I'd never get around to it.
It's just like, if there's a person who lives
in the same city that you do, you never see
them.
But if they live somewhere completely different,
"Oh, I'm coming to wherever for a day," and
you end up seeing them.
And it's been the same thing for me with call-while-driving.
It's like, "I'm going to call somebody," and
so this is that process.
Tim Ferriss: Stephen, I'm so continually impressed
with not just the breadth of your thinking,
but how you log and track and interpret so
much data.
I think that I take a lot of notes, but you
mentioned, at the top of this conversation,
a quarter million pages, something along those
lines.
It's just incredible.
Stephen Wolfram: That's the stuff on paper
actually.
I have three million emails as well, so yeah,
a lot of stuff, over a long period of time.
Tim Ferriss: So, you have a lot of stuff,
over a long period of time, and I would love
to, at some point, do a round two.
I'm sure we could do themed conversations
on probably several dozen different topics.
Is there anything else that you would like
to mention, in this conversation, or call
my audience's attention to —
Stephen Wolfram: Oh, my.
Tim Ferriss: — anything at all, in terms
of closing remarks, comments, any grievances
you'd like to air publicly, really anything
at all that you'd like to mention before we
—
Stephen Wolfram: Makes me want to ask you
for a bunch of personal productivity hacks
and so on and the what am I missing type thing
—
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Yeah.
Stephen Wolfram: — because one slowly accumulates
these things.
And I find I'll try things and probably two-thirds
of the things I try work, and one third don't.
But it's keep trying them, but anyway.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Stephen Wolfram: So, I think, no, we've covered
all kinds of things.
Tim Ferriss: I look forward to hopefully seeing
you again in person, at some point, but this
has been delightful and very fun for me.
I've taken copious notes, so I will be doing
lots of follow up on my own.
And you seem to be doing pretty well on the
productivity side.
If I think of anything that is a gross omission,
I will be sure to send it to you.
Stephen Wolfram: Okay.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: People can find you on Twitter,
Stephen, that's a ph, Stephen_Wolfram, then
Facebook/stephenwolfram, linkedin.com, also,
your name and then the website stephenwolfram.com.
And we'll link to everything that you've mentioned.
Is there anything that you would like to point
people to that is top of mind for you, at
the moment, or any resources that people may
not find on their own?
Stephen Wolfram: Well, let's see.
The stuff I write ends up in writings.stephenwolfram.com.
And I put lots of effort into writing these
things, so hopefully some people find them
fun to read.
Although even the process of writing them,
as I was explaining, is a useful process in
its own right.
There's also a recent thing, for me, is we
just launched our Wolfram Institute, that's,
I suppose, an attempted productivity hack.
My company, which I started now 36 years ago,
is my machine for turning ideas that I have
into real things.
And it's 800 people who are really, really
good at doing that and coming up with their
own ideas as well.
But that's been a thing, where mostly, we
make products, but one of the problems I've
been trying to solve is, if you're making
basic science, what's the machine that does
that?
And I've carved off a bit of resources from
the company and so on, to do it, but we just
recently launched Wolfram Institute, which
is a thing whose goal is to do basic science.
And that's a new thing in the last just few
weeks, and so stay tuned for interesting things
that are happening there.
And I guess there'll be yet more live streaming
of science in action and so on there.
So, those are a few things.
And I suppose the other, I have to plug my
life work, which my life work is building
Wolfram Language and Wolfram|Alpha and Mathematica
and so on, which are all part of the same
idea of make the world computational.
And I suppose the one pitch I would make is,
what we've built, I can inexorably see is
an artifact from the future.
And in other words, the direction that things
are going in, is going in this direction of
representing the world computationally and
being able to really make use of that.
But there are a few million people who actually
do make use of it in our technology stack,
but there are a lot of millions of people
who don't and that this is an inexorable piece
of the future.
And it's a big advantage if you can grab the
magic from the future.
I've done a lot of work with kids, who are
learning our stuff and doing projects and
so on, and I've taken to referring to learning
computational language is a superpower.
It's something that you get to do that, and
then you can do all kinds of magic things
with it.
Anyway, so learn that superpower, and more
people should do it.
And it's one of these things where you can
kind of see, in the world, when things involve
big ideas, there's a certain, inexorable slowness
to the way that they get adopted.
And there are always some number of early
adopters, who are the ones that run out in
front, and so my parting pitch would be, if
you don't understand computational language
and Wolfram Language and so on, try to understand
it because it is, for me, the — you talk
about productivity hacks.
The biggest amplifier, hugest productivity
hack is the whole computational language idea.
That's what all the things I've done in science
and in technology, they are all based on that
idea and the tower of technology that we built
around that.
So that's my parting, ultimate productivity
hack.
Tim Ferriss: Wonderful.
And for everybody listening, Mathematica,
Wolfram|Alpha, Wolfram Language, we will link
to all of these things in the show notes,
at tim.blog/podcast.
And you can just search Wolfram, W-O-L-F-R-A-M,
and that will pop right up.
Stephen, I really enjoy learning from you
because you're not only an incredible thinker,
technologist, I'm sure there are many multi-hyphenate
labels I could apply, but you're a very gifted
communicator and teacher.
So, the practical impact of what you do is
not just manifested through the products used
by millions of people and that will be used,
in some form or another, by many, many millions
more, but also in the principled and systematic
thinking that you can share and do share with
people, including kids, including with non-technical
muggles, who are nonetheless very curious,
like myself and no doubt with many, many millions
of listeners on this podcast.
So thank you.
I really, really appreciate the time you take
to do what you do and the time you've also
taken to have this conversation.
Stephen Wolfram: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: So, thank you very much.
And to everybody listening, I'll plug it one
more time.
You can go to tim.blog/podcast, for the show
notes for all things we've mentioned in this
episode and in all episodes.
And until next time, be a little bit kinder
than is necessary.
Be very curious.
Definitely paddle early for the superpowers
that you can get ahead of, in terms of early
adoption, like those that Stephen was mentioning.
And thank you for tuning in.